[Music]
personal that will govern all decisions
pertaining to immigration the time is
overdue to develop a new screening test
for the threats we face today extreme
this is gonna be an awful lot of
information and will this mean that
people have delays and getting their
visas to come the United States will
this mean fewer people will want to come
what is the State Department doing with
this data let's bring in our panel to
talk about it Tom Rogan commentary
writer for the Washington Examiner and
Garen political correspondent at the
Washington Post and Eli Lake columnist
for Bloomberg view welcome to all of you
great to have you on our lightning round
Friday Tom I'll start with you what do
you make of these announced changes well
I think that the exigent point here is
that the Trump administration is trying
to address an issue that the Obama
administration had grappled with and
that is the environment of Isis
returnest but people who hold perhaps
you you pass ports who might be able to
come to the United States on a Visa
Waiver program and that potentially they
could sort of navigate their way through
the process the the real issue though I
think here is that this is kind of
political trying to tick a box it's
trying to say if that ever happened if a
British citizen who was part of Isis
then carry out an attack in Kansas City
one day while we try to develop some
more safeguards ultimately though
someone who is a terrorist is probably
not going to put down on the form they
were so I don't know how much efficacy
in a count of terrorism terms that we
actually have yeah okay so folks know
this is these are some of the bullet
points about what they're going to be
looking for applicants will have to turn
over social media history from five
years prior to applying they say not
passwords and that kind of thing but
handles and you know accounts email
addresses and telephone numbers five
years back international travel five
years back any prior immigration
violations and any family connections to
terrorism and you know and Tom sort of
hit on this do we think they're going to
disclose any terror connections through
the family yeah I mean this isn't
actually that extreme as vetting goes it
doesn't apply to people who aren't even
who are not applying for visas for
example and and no I mean if you have
something to hide there there are ways
to hide it
I there are some real civil liberties
concerns with this but it is not really
that much of us it's not substantially
totally different than questions that
are already asked what what makes it
different is that it goes into the realm
of social media but visa applicants are
already asked for a lot of information
about their associations with other
people and that will be the legal
argument that the administration uses in
an inevitable challenge that this really
isn't that different
yeah and ela the estimates are that
millions of people will actually be
impacted by this all those applying for
visas not just to come here I mean there
it's a it's a higher standard of what
you're asking for to come but do you
think it'll work well you know we have
two separate two things one is a
counterterrorism question where the big
concern now are people who are already
here being radicalized online the other
though is a more interesting question
which is you know in the Cold War there
if you wanted to come to the United
States and apply to become a citizen you
couldn't be a declared communist are we
now getting to a point where you can't
really be you know what for lack of a
better a radical Islamist if you come to
the United States and that is a separate
question from whether or not you might
actually be a terrorist and that is that
is one or you have to sort of see how
this policy plays out and I think that
you know in my view Americans should be
able to hold any opinion and participate
in the public square but constitutional
rights of American citizens do not
necessarily apply to people who are
applying to come here so that is I think
really where the rubber will meet the
road on that well I'm waiting for the
first lawsuit if it's not already been
filed and when these things become
official that will happen yeah we can
watch for that okay let's talk about
topic two now which is Hillary Clinton
out talking again about criticism of her
and how she's handled this post-election
period here's what she's saying people
said that to me you know mostly people
in the press
for whatever reason like oh you know go
away go away and I had a one of the
young people works for me go back and do
a bit of research they never said that
to any man who was not elected she's
wrong comparing herself to those male
candidates Republican and Democratic who
lost presidential elections as well they
were much more gracious about it well
you know and we all talk to people who
are actively within the Democratic Party
and Democratic leadership who say no
they actually do want her to stop
talking about the election it's
absolutely a fair question for Democrats
to ask whether she's helping or hurting
but the larger question here of like
should she be saying these things and is
a different standard being applied to
her I think is also something that needs
we all need to look at in in the
political sphere and frankly that
Democrats will will need to look at as
well because for at the same time as
there are definitely Democrats who wish
that she would leave the stage at least
a little bit there are also a lot of
other Democrats who think she's being
treated unfairly and not only by
Republicans not only by the white house
I think she's being treated unfairly by
by other Democrats and that she does
have a voice and she has something to
say to be able to say it I think the
first point is here can we remember
objectively can we remember a failed
presidential candidate who has been in
in basic terms as bad a loser as he has
been in many different ways whether
there be in India the more recent
comments and secondly if we look at for
example recent presidential candidates
in terms of their deportment after
losing an election there has been the
sort of impulse to actually sort of you
know MIT Romney for example in 2012 in
terms of the President Obama's reaction
on Russia though Commerce there he
didn't really press that so aggressively
afterwards so I think to some degree
this is part of her own making and
actually again it comes to that point
the party wants to move forwards okay
now briskly we're gonna get through
because we want all of your winners and
losers for the week away we'll start
with you
winner Roseanne Barr
after 21 years she comes back and it's a
big hit and you know despite the fact
that her character just like the
comedienne is a big Trump voter and the
loser is Donald Trump's Iran strategy
which i think was actually doing a lot
better than people thought with his
comments if this is true that he there
there's gonna be a premature exit from
Syria then that's basically leaving in a
very important country in the Middle
East to the Iranian Revolutionary Guard
Corps not a good call a lot of
developing situation there Obama's
policy okay so my winner is Vladimir
Putin and even though yes the largest
expulsion of Russian diplomats ever
happened this week he is still
essentially being able to bold his way
through and all the international
outrage u.s. and other at the poisoning
of a man and his daughter on British
soil and when given the opportunity to
directly confront him over that the
president will do so my loser is David
Shulkin not only did he get fired and
what is probably the least surprising
development of the week but his
explanation for it for why said he was
you know politically targeted really
fell flat and it means that his
successor who already had a hard job has
an even harder one but very quickly Jim
mattis is the winner
I think partisan hyperventilation chill
out - we need to chill out more and the
second other loser Jeremy Corbyn British
Labour Party leader anti-semitism has he
proved on his part and Theresa May is
now up in the polls nicely done you all